stunning numbers show a surge of illegal
immigrants at the southern border last
month Customs and Border Protection
reporting now that there were more than
two hundred eleven thousand illegals
caught in April
that is a 10 percent jump from March and
that was just before title 42 expired
one week ago today
the CBP also reports it captured a
staggering 16 people on the FBI's Terror
watch list that's more than all of
fiscal year 2017 through 2020.
combined Arizona Congressman Andy Biggs
says don't forget about the godaways
the bigger problem is we don't know who
they didn't interdict we don't know
whether their their terrorists we don't
know if they're criminal gang members we
don't know if they're bringing drugs
across we don't know if they're bringing
children in in Sex and human trafficking
cases
this is a it's a massive problem
border communities are now all over the
United States but particularly those
States along the southern border with
Mexico they're struggling particularly
hard in El Paso Texas illegal immigrants
sleeping in the streets and thousands
more waiting right across the border in
Mexico officials there say they are now
the weather has cleared bracing for the
worst
desperate and they're going to try to to
cross in an irregular fashion
um that being either you know coming
across the river or going out into the
desert or trying to jump over the wall
which are all very very dangerous
looking Governor Greg Abbott of Texas
governor first of all tell me how things
are going right now
well things uh have changed a little bit
because of what we showed last week and
that is the Texas National Guard and the
Texas Department of Public Safety are
now repelling illegal immigrants who are
trying to cross the border so it's
causing the cartels to have to
recalibrate what they're doing they're
holding tens of hundreds of thousands of
people back trying to figure out where
and how to go as they cross the border
so it's just a chess match right now
with the cartels that said one thing
that we're doing as we speak is to add
more National Guard and DPS officers on
the front lines of the Border as well as
add more of those razor wire border
walls and fences to make sure that we're
going to be able to prevent people from
entering Texas illegally so I pointed
this out last week and I said that some
of the numbers should come down because
of what you're doing and at one point I
remember you were deploying like 10 000
Texas National Guards I mean earlier in
the process so what you're doing is
making a difference I haven't heard it
do you have the full throated public
support from the federal government
giving you credit and an attaboy for
what's going on down there
to the contrary Joe Biden was asking
about it I think yesterday the day
before and he scoffed about it you know
but the fact of the matter is there's
only one governmental entity in the
entire United States of America that is
repelling people who are trying to enter
illegally and that's the state of Texas
wow the CDC is reporting that nearly 110
000 Americans have died from drug
overdoses in 2022 becoming the deadliest
year
on record
I know your state of Texas
the Senate there just passed a bill
allowing for murder charges to be
brought in certain fentanyl related
deaths how will that work
well first to show the magnitude of the
problem Texas law enforcement alone has
seized enough fentanyl to kill every man
woman and child in the entire United
States of America this is a potential
catastrophe for the country and there
has to be consequences for it one of the
consequences that we are adding is to
create a murder charge for someone who
laces a some other type of drug with
fentanyl which is what happens all the
time and a person uses it and dies from
it so we're converting an overdose to
finding to a poisoning finding and
classifying it as murder and will
prosecute his murder so we can put these
a deadly either cartel members or their
counterparts here in the state of Texas
Behind Bars you know I know you're doing
your state is doing sort of specific
work where this is you've got a special
lab that your DPS has told me about just
real quickly how much more do you think
the federal government could be doing I
mean have they visited that lap
uh they have not and so you say how much
more they could they do the first thing
they do would be the most that they have
done they're not really stepping up and
doing anything that I have seen to try
to stop the inflow of fentanyl remember
that the the component parts of fentanyl
come from China and they're used by drug
cartels in Mexico to lace onto other
drugs that are then sold in the United
States Biden should be fighting on the
front lines against China against Mexico
with regard to people in the United
States being poisoned I have seen
nothing from the body Administration
fighting back against these countries
for the poisoning and killing of
Americans look uh he'd have to add that
spycraft that flew over the entire
continental U.S to the list of things to
hold China accountable for last week I
read he's not likely to even do that
going to give them a pass let me move to
this the Texas state legislature again
passed a bill that would ban doctors
from providing gender affirming care to
children it's now headed to your desk
governor and right now there are similar
laws on the books and several other red
states were going to put up the map for
everybody to see if it's signed into law
in your state it would become the
largest state to ban these procedures
for minor children these are young kids
governor
so listen I'm not going to make any
secret about it I'll be signing it and
uh Harris this is about protecting
children now remember this and and that
is a person under the age of 18 they
don't have the mental capacity uh to
make a life-changing decision to uh lose
their sex organs in the state of Texas
if you're under at the age of 18 you
can't get a tattoo you can't buy
cigarettes and so many other things but
people think that they should be able to
make a decision to permanently alter
their sex organs that's just outrageous
in Texas we believe uh that cutting off
the child's sex organs is child abuse
and it's going to be treated that way by
law
well and you've got that added uh
situation in some states that says you
don't even have to tell your parents
I've interviewed a couple of those
parents who found out that their kids
were being exposed to things at secret
clubs and whatnot at Schools elementary
age kids sixth graders so I'm sure that
it will Encompass some of that as well
that's a big discussion and you said you
make no bones about it you're going to
sign that bill into law Governor good to
see you we'll be done thank you thank
you Harris
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 pm Eastern or set your DVR
also don't forget to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights